[Musica]
sapete che dieci fra le 15 invenzioni
più grandi di tutti i tempi sono
concentrate tra il 1700 ed oggi se
consideriamo la storia dell'essere umano
dalle prime grandi civiltà in poi stiamo
parlando di più o meno 6 mila anni
questo vuol dire che durante gli ultimi
secoli
il processo di innovazione tecnologica
ha subito una crescita esponenziale
guida autonoma intelligenza artificiale
realtà virtuale block chain sanità hi
tech tra dieci anni probabilmente
saranno una tecnologia ordinaria comune
se non un po obsoleta
sembriamo proprio non voler togliere il
piede da questo acceleratore
ma invece possiamo dire la stessa cosa
per quanto riguarda l'evoluzione
dell'uomo dell'essere umano come io come
persona nella società nell'ambiente
nell'universo
no
siamo più o meno gli stessi di mille
anni fa poco è stato raggiunto se ci
paragoniamo al processo di innovazione
tecnologica
esistono ancora guerre discriminazioni
disparità sociali crimini di ogni genere
ma allora io mi domando possiamo davvero
parlare di progresso quello stesso uomo
che è andato sulla luna che inventato
elettronica informatica che ha permesso
le telecomunicazioni da due parti
opposte del pianeta non riesce a
cambiare qualcosa di così vicino a sé
quale rivoluzione coinvolge l'essere
umano quale miglioramento stiamo
cercando di apportare noi nel nostro
rapporto con gli altri con il mondo
intero a cosa serve tutta questa
tecnologia così strabiliante se non
abbiamo ancora imparato a vivere in
armonia con noi stessi e con gli altri
proprio per questo a cosa serve a cosa
serve questa tecnologia
possiamo davvero parlare di progresso
secondo me sì secondo me sì è tutto
tutto si riduce a una sola e splendida
azione
avere fiducia e non intendo la
definizione di fiducia che trovate nel
dizionario intendo qualcosa di molto
molto più grande una super fiducia una
fiducia non una di quelle fasulle ma una
di quelle incrollabili che sa che crea
che plasma che crea certezze si certezze
questa è una parola chiave quanti di noi
possono dire di avere certezze nella
vita quando tutto viene messo in
discussione quando tutto sembra per
forza nascondere un secondo fine ma io
invece sono convinto che una vita fatta
di certezza e una vita passata ad avere
fiducia a dare fiducia sia una vita
migliore non solo per noi ma anche per
gli altri e ne sono convinto perché ho
visto l'effetto che avuto questo nella
mia vita le possibilità che ho creato
gli obiettivi che ho raggiunto i
desideri che ho esaudito e dall'altra
parte invece ciò che non sono riuscito
ad ottenere
ok come facciamo però ad applicare
questo concetto di super fiducia nella
vita di tutti i giorni
beh per esempio credere in qualcosa
credere con totale convinzione e
fermezza che si realizzi qualcosa in
qualche modo la rende vera basti pensare
a ciò che è vero per noi non è vero ciò
che è vero ma è vero ciò che crediamo
sia vero è come se l'universo creasse
una dimensione solo per noi solo per noi
questo è il nostro potere cambiare
modificare il nostro universo
condizionarlo cambiarlo tante volte
renderlo un posto dove tutto è possibile
dove tutto prende forma ma solo se ci
crediamo solo se abbiamo super fiducia
altro che superman o huurman noi siamo i
più grandi supereroi del mondo ora
immaginate se fossimo in grado di
controllare in modo assoluto questa
convinzione questa fermezza come piace
chiamarlo a me questa fiducia super
fiducia e fossimo in grado di dire con
estrema sicurezza io ce la farò io
raggiungerò questo risultato questo
obiettivo anzi fossimo in grado di
riconoscerlo in fondo al nostro cuore
fino al midollo come qualcosa che già
successa sono sicuro che accadrebbe
pensateci
avete mai desiderato qualcosa così
ardentemente avete mai creduto così
fermamente da ottenerla è come se
l'universo si modificasse venisse
incontro al nostro al nostro personale
desiderio conosco persone che grazie a
questo hanno fatto cose incredibili sono
guarite da malattie hanno superato
momenti di totale disperazione hanno
preso in mano le redini della propria
vita e l'hanno condotta verso la
direzione che indicava il proprio cuore
ecco anche a me è successo diverse volte
parlano di qualcosa di un po più
semplice per esempio come quella volta
che sono andato in inghilterra con
un'amica la quale proprio durante i suoi
ultimi viaggi verso quali 0
dell'atlantico era stata vittima di
ritardi infiniti cancellazioni dei voli
e anche per quel viaggio si aspettava il
peggio ma io invece ricordo questa
sensazione quasi viscerale che sarebbe
andato tutto per il meglio ecco non solo
andò tutto per il meglio ma uscì anche
il sole in inghilterra a ottobre e
sappiamo tutti contro questo è un evento
eccezionale
oppure settembre 2017 ultimo esame prima
della sessione di laurea triennale che
si sa che si sarebbe tenuta alla fine di
quel mese
tentiamo con l'esame per la terza volta
non vi dico l'ansia e la preoccupazione
se un passo questo esame non mi posso
laureare se non se non mi posso laurea
non mi posso scrivere la magistrale se
non mi scrivo la magistrale perde del
tempo prezioso
ma poi mi sono fermato e mi sono detto
basta riccardo basta con queste ansie
con queste preoccupazioni mettici
mettici il cuore e ce la farai e non ero
il solo dall'ami fiducia ma tante
persone dalla mia famiglia mini ci
credevano in me e sono sicuro che aver
avuto attorno tutte quelle persone che
credevano che sarebbe andato tutto per
il meglio abbia tolto quell'ostacolo
tutto ciò che lo rendeva tale
ecco in quel settembre 2017 non solo
passa in esame lo passa con un ottimo
voto e mi laurea in tempo
ecco da questo capiamo quanto è
importante
questa super fiducia per le relazioni
quanto possa fare del bene avere fiducia
cioè credere in una persona a edifica la
arricchisce la materializza come
presenza sicura nel nostro personale
universo quanto è bello dare fiducia
quanto è bello poter contare ciecamente
su qualcuno è quanto è bello e questa
fiducia è contagiosa porta positività e
quindi gioia una persona che viene
riconosciuta riconoscerà una persona
fatta custode della nostra fiducia
sarà una persona più sicura più felice e
sarà portata ad averne per gli altri ma
invece quante volte dubitiamo quante
volte siamo portati a pensare male
quando una situazione non è chiara la
nostra certezza per essere tale dovrebbe
essere smossa solo da montagne le
relazioni cioè ciò che veramente ci ci
rende felice ci fa stare bene si basano
su questa certezza che viene costruita
pian piano con cura e che ci permette di
vivere in tranquillità
insomma diciamocelo in un modo più
concreto
avere fiducia avere super fiducia vuol
dire avere meno problemi vuol dire farsi
meno problemi vuol dire rimuovere la
maggior parte delle ansie che diminuisce
la qualità della nostra vita
e se anche una sola volta questa fiducia
vacilla viene meno e noi non crediamo
più per tutto il resto del tempo ci ha
permesso di fare e ci permetterà di fare
cose incredibili
ecco senza neanche rendersene conto è
sbocciato il fiore della fiducia un
fiore
che simboleggia una primavera una
rinascita per l'uomo per l'essere umano
che con i suoi petali ci ricorda quanto
è profondo il suo significato un fiore
che va alimentato con la nostra più
cieca fermezza per aprirci ad orizzonti
inimmaginabili un fiore che è la chiave
di volta nelle volte del futuro e c
a questo punto la vostra domanda è come
ci si riesce beh innanzitutto ci si deve
credere
e poi ci si prova un po come quando si
impara a camminare
all'inizio non è che siamo proprio
bravissimi ma poi dopo tempo dopo tante
cadute camminiamo senza neanche pensarci
più eque pur essendo esperti camminatori
ogni tanto inciampiamo ancora i cani ne
sono la prova vivente perché sono
inciampato poco fa prima di salire sul
palco
ma questa è un'altra storia quello che
invece volevo dire è che non dubitiamo
mai di non saper camminare
nonostante ogni tanto inciampiamo ancora
e così dovrebbe essere per questa nostra
super fiducia per questo nostro per
questo nostro super fiducia per questa
nostra certezza il progresso non può più
essere solo o meglio principalmente
tecnologico dobbiamo schiacciare
l'acceleratore verso un progresso del io
della persona della società
forse non potremo cambiare direttamente
il mondo intero ma sicuramente possiamo
cambiare i nostri personali universi e
se molti di noi né assumessero il totale
controllo beh sarebbe come cambiare
anche quello degli altri
immaginiamo quasi 8 miliardi di persone
che desiderano ardentemente che credono
fermamente in un mondo giusto
saldo integro
ecco che d'un tratto non sembra così
impossibile ma invece questo mondo
prende forma diventa tangibile diventa
vero
solo così potremo parlare di progresso
solo così potremo dire di aver reso il
mondo davvero migliore un mondo che muta
unanime sotto il desiderio di tutti
ognuno di noi può essere partecipe della
rivoluzione più grande di tutti i tempi
ogni giorno dire a noi stessi io ci
credo dire a chi sta di fronte a noi io
credo in te
grazie
[Musica]